there's been many relationships broken
up because of her Peter Webber and
Victoria Fuller's hometown date was a
doozy don't know about your great guy
and I don't think they deserve linear
on a day that's right now
you know I do
actually friend to her yeah on Monday
night's episode of The Bachelor Pete the
pilots ex-girlfriend
Marissa pence showed up to warn him
about Victoria just um yeah I'm from
here and I just know like what a good
guy you are and I would hate for like
any of who you are to be affected by so
that's really all say Peter and Marissa
dated for about six months back in two
thousand twelve years later Marissa met
Victoria in Virginia Beach after she
moved there from LA and needless to say
Marissa not exactly a fan of Victoria I
saw my complications with Victoria and
you know I always tried I always tried
to get along with her but the last night
that her and I hung out before she left
for the doctor was like awful naturally
Peter beeline straight for Victoria who
was living that deny till you die like
for her to say that's very disappointing
I haven't broken up any relationships so
what relationship does she say that I
breakup but Peter seemed to be taking
Marissa's warning pretty seriously she
didn't give me details
this is these are her
and obviously you can see how that would
put me in bad headspace is it just me or
do you feel like you need way more info
from Marissa well you're in luck because
et chatted with Peters ex and she dished
on why she confronted Peter with those
claims about Victoria and it's a wild
ride starting with the very first time
they met one of my very first encounters
with her was she was gonna slash my
tires because I was hanging out with one
of her boyfriends yeah you heard that
right
she claims Victoria said she was going
to slash her freakin tires anyway the
two ran in the same social circles and
according to Marissa still hung out
after all of that I saw on my
complications with Victoria and you know
I always tried I always tried to get
along with her but the last night that
her and I hung out before she left for
The Bachelor was like awful
Marissa alleges that Victoria was
bragging about being cast on the show
and how it was gonna make her famous
like oh my gosh like this is
embarrassing and I gave it like Connie
was it's a little awkward for me because
my ex-boyfriend cut to that hometown
date in Virginia Beach Marissa says she
went there with no intentions of talking
to Peter but decided to approach him at
the end of the date I took it upon
myself to name and have a conversation
with them and she says telling Peter to
be careful was her way of saying you
need to send Victoria packing I just
wanted him to end his relationship with
Victoria I you know I kind of knew when
I found out that she was going on the
show how this would play out I was there
to warn him and present act if he asked
but I wasn't there to you know slander
her name or say bad words or call her
names I was not there for that that's
not me that's not what who I wanted to
be portrayed I since all of that went
down Marissa says she's reached out to
Peter but she hasn't gotten a response
and get this she also bumped into
Victoria yeah we had a semi
confrontation at one of the local bars
here a couple weekend doctor she got
back from the bachelor she had like
yells across the bar like you're closer
to me and my group of friends which is
like I does words do not hurt me and you
know I was confident in what I did
awkward this season of The Bachelor
really is a gift that just keeps on
giving and you can count on ET to be
right here to bring you all the
highlights until next time on Hallie
Stevens see you soon
[Music]